[Música]
eu gostaria de convidar vocês nesse
momento inicial por uma pequena e breve
experiência
gostaria que vocês fecharem seus olhos
respire profundamente relaxem ombros
braços pernas
lembre se vocês pequenos
qual a primeira imagem que vem de você
criança o que você desejava um beijo um
abraço brincar com os amigos
respire um pouco mais e agora livres de
você na adolescência
nessa fase a gente quer transformar o
mundo
imaginamos como vai ser a nossa idade
adulta o que seremos a vida passa como
um piscar de olhos e respire abra seus
olhos lentamente
estou aqui para dividir o meu momento o
meu tempo com o seu esse tempo que é
marcado pelo momento inicial em que
respiramos pela primeira vez e nascemos
até o momento da nossa morte para a
ciência vida é o espaço
tempo e de concepção ea morte de um
organismo para instalar em tempo é uma
ilusão uma ilusão que separa passado
presente e futuro
para outros a cada momento cada segundo
é muito precioso é um momento que jamais
se repete
segundo baú e estabeleceu várias
reflexões sobre a nossa modernidade é
sobre esse período da pós modernidade
ele diz que vivemos numa sociedade de
consumo e como o consumo é convidar os
nomes mas eleva o consumo não
valorizamos a durabilidade das coisas
muito menos das pessoas
igualamos tudo que é velho é tudo que é
velho a descartável obsoleto destinado a
lata do lixo a esse conceito nos faz
crer que só temos valor enquanto estamos
vivendo em idade produtiva e reprodutiva
que aquele tempo em que a gente começa a
nossa carreira profissional que a gente
pensa em comprar um apartamento um carro
próprio
se vamos casar se vamos ter filhos se
vamos fazer viagens internacionais
com a chegada da menopausa e da
andropausa ea proximidade da
aposentadoria
a gente começa a ficar com medo desse
processo de envelhecimento
as rugas se acentuam os cabelos
embranquecem e ficamos apavorados com a
velhice e com a morte
esses dois temas sempre me assustaram ao
longo da vida
a velhice ea morte
lembro me bem que quando tinha 15 anos
de idade eu imaginava que eu iria mover
40 anos fantásticos iria morrer
subitamente no auge sem passar pela
velhice suas doenças
recordo também o porquê que vinham esses
medos porque o pib as minhas avós
e clarice sentadas nas suas varandas
velhas doentes com a tristeza estampada
nos olhos com a pobreza agarrada nas
mãos e o sofrimento fincado no coração
no brasil em 1960 a expectativa de vida
era que vivesse os 52 anos de idade ou
seja um ano antes do meu nascimento quem
nós e se viveria 52 anos
hoje a expectativa de vida é que vivamos
ganhamos esses quase 25 anos a mais de
vida por conta da implementação de
saneamento básico da água tratada dos
avanços da medicina e também dos
medicamentos e vacinas potentes que
tratam quase todas as doenças
ganhamos esses 25 anos a mais e o que
vamos fazer com eles
nós temos medo do envelhecimento porque
associam os que envelhecer é ser velho é
ser descartável é ser julgado numa lata
de lixo
se eu tenho eu tenho dinheiro né
eu posso ser uma pessoa idosa bonita bem
tratada com poucas doenças e você não a
idosa feliz se eu sou pobre eu recebo
como herança o pacote de rugas flacidez
manchas e uma velhice extremamente
sofrida
o vídeo que nós vamos ver agora em
seguida ele foi produzido em 2012 e foi
exibido em rede estadual pelo instituto
ame suas rugas e objetivo desse vídeo
era mostrar com as pessoas para as
pessoas que o que nos acontece ao longo
da vida é a experiência
um homem se lança ao mar aprendeu-se
golpes
o ganha pão com que construindo a sua
história seu sustento sua língua o que o
bai ensino nunca se perde não se esvai
fica velho do que experiência o que nos
acontece
sou que é feito com a experiência do
tempo o tempo respeito
[Música]
criamos esse instituto em 2008 com o
objetivo central de mudar o paradigma do
que seja o envelhecimento humano no
brasil quando iniciei meus estudos
a minha pós graduações e gerontologia no
brasil e no méxico eu tive certeza de
que pior do que envelhecemos é termos
medo desse processo de envelhecimento
quando partir para os estudos de livros
e congressos internacionais
eu pensei por um instante que eu pudesse
encontrar em algum lugar do mundo o
hellish da longevidade
depois de estar em cuba e conhecer os
estudos dos idosos centenários que lá
vivem
eu descobri que não existe tal elixir da
longevidade não existe mesmo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pois é
não tem jeito a gente envelhece
hoje eu não quero mais morrer como
desejavam os meus 15 anos cedo porque eu
tenho imenso prazer em estar viva porque
só quem está vivo envelhece mas temos
alguns problemas do envelhecimento nos
traz uma dependência e muletas como
esses papéis que eu trago aqui né então
envelhecer também tem isso eu gostaria
de conversar com vocês sobre um trabalho
apresentado pelo geriatra brasileiro
renato maia ele presidiu a associação
internacional de geriatria e
gerontologia e ele escreveu um livro
descida você quanto e como quer viver
nesse livro ele fala do capital de saúde
que deve ser administrado por nós ao
longo da vida para termos o
envelhecimento bem sucedido o primeiro
capital que ele se refere que a gente
tem que aprender a administrar é o
capital biológico o capital biológico é
aquele que nos define geneticamente com
nascimento
por isso é muito importante que
conheçamos a história é familiar dos
nossos pais avós bisavós e sabemos se
eles tiverem alguma doença hipertensão à
diabetes
a demência é o cânceres para que a gente
possa entender e modificar isso
o segundo capital aqui é o doutor relato
se refere é o capital social
o capital social também representa 25%
desse capital de saúde e está
relacionado ao lugar onde nascemos que
políticas públicas existem nesses
lugares se a previdência pública e se
ela vai atender às nossas necessidades
quando envelhecemos se também esse
sistema público de saúde podem nos
amparar na velhice
se tivéssemos ácido por exemplo
áfrica não viveríamos mais de 50 anos
tivemos a sorte de nascer uns no brasil
e no sul do brasil isso lhe dá nos dá um
diferencial muito importante
o outro capital que ele se refere é o
capital emocional e pasmem vocês ele
representa 50% desse capital de saúde ou
seja um dos mais relevantes
esse capital emocional ele surge na
infância quando a gente aprende a
administrar as nossas habilidades
cognitivas e emocionais
se aprendemos a superar desafios se
temos a tendência é sermos depressivos
se temos medos né de superar obstáculos
como é que então eu faço pra ter uma
gestão bem bem bem bem sucedida ou não
bem sucedida
desses três capitais se eu não faço uma
boa gestão ignora um histórico genético
o meu histórico não é eu sou ativo
socialmente não muda as mudanças do país
onde estou vivendo e também não me
percebo eu posso ser uma pessoa idosa
depressiva com muitas doenças
posso ter momentos enfermidades longas
posso morrer com muito sofrimento e
antes da expectativa de vida que a gente
viu lá atrás que santos 74 anos
se eu faço uma boa gestão desses
capitais
eu posso eu terei com certeza mais
longevidade doenças por curta
enfermidades por curto período de tempo
e viveremos com certeza acima dos 85
anos de idade
entretanto só administrar esses capitais
não é o suficiente
nós temos que mudar cada um de nós
o paradigma do que seja o envelhecimento
para que quando nós todos fomos muito
idosos não sejamos obsoletos e não nos
coloquem numa lata de lixo
simone bouwa escreveu em 1970
livro velhice realidade incômoda
nesse livro ela denuncia denunciou
silenciamento kevin todo mundo é por que
é contra os idosos ninguém falava sobre
isso eles eram escondidos sim 70 quando
simone escreveu o livro aves
silenciamento hoje ainda vivemos com o
preconceito com as pessoas que
envelhecem
portanto não há outra alternativa
nós temos que aceitar esse processo de
envelhecimento porque é muito melhor ea
gente pode fazer muito mais coisas
os brasileiros quase todos rejeitam o
processo de envelhecimento dados da
sociedade brasileira de cirurgia
plástica indicam que mais de 800 mil
pessoas por ano realizam procedimentos
estéticos de modificação do próprio
corpo em busca de uma juventude eterna
entretanto pessoas não há como deter
esse processo que é normal e que é que é
bacana que temos que aceitá lo
esses dados das pirâmides etárias do
brasil mostram que nós em 40 anos
teremos o triplo de idosos que temos em
em 2010 nós somos 20 milhões de idosos
em 2050 seremos 66 milhões
isso significa dizer que nós teremos
muito mais idosos que crianças vivendo
no brasil daqui a 40 anos
temos os dados as informações as bolsas
quais são os meus conselhos o que eu vim
dizer pra vocês
pratiquem exercícios físicos como um
produto sem agrotóxico deixem de comer
gordura
tomo vitamina todos os dias como a
gelatina os secretários com colágeno
faça amor quando o amor vier faça sexo
quando puder
entretanto não há uma receita certa para
cada um de nós
jeci galã é uma escocesa
ela viveu acima dos 100 anos qual é a
receita dela para a longevidade
primeiro não se casar ela dizia que os
homens fazem mal à saúde
ela também dizia que ela também dizia
que tinha se praticar atividade física e
comer aquela tigelinha de mingau quente
todos os dias de manhã eu trago o
exemplo do professor hermógenes é um
grande nome do yoga brasileiro ele com
40 anos de idade descobriu que estava em
fase terminal com tuberculose
ele fez uma mudança radical na sua vida
passou a praticar ioga e fazer meditação
todos os dias transformou a alimentação
dele entregando na não fumava não bebia
e ele dobrou a possibilidade de vida
dele morreu depois dos 90 anos de idade
nego também o exemplo de leandrão bregas
é uma mexicana que viveu acima dos 127
anos muito querida e ela disse o
seguinte o segredo dela era comer
chocolate todos os dias
dormir muito né não sei pra que dormir
tanto mas enfim a e também ela não se
casou quando soube da história da
leandra eu sou eu não como chocolate que
eu não gosto eu já me casei três vezes
voltou à beira da morte e agora o último
exemplo é de uma blumenauense ela viveu
aqui em blumenau da mística pereira ela
viveu 114 anos
ao contrário das outras ela casou
enviuvou duas vezes foi mãe de 12 filhos
sete dos filhos dela morreram antes
pensa 9114 eles morreram muitos jovens
com 90 e na receita dela de longevidade
é o cardápio dela qual era polenta pirão
e lingüiça frita garotada é isso que ela
comia para viver bastante para os
religiosos
a vida eterna buda porém advertiu
tudo que começa um dia inevitavelmente
acaba a eternidade existe no momento
presente
portanto aproveite esse tempo entre seu
nascimento e sua morte
pois é
vocês pensaram que ia trazer certezas
que ia trazer elixires que eu ia trazer
longevidade que ia trazer vida eterna
não trago nada eu não tenho certezas
a única certeza que eu tenho é que um
dia todos nós iremos morrer
namastê
[Aplausos]